i want to bring up andrew cuomo because
it's funny
that's why i why should i lie it's funny
it's a comedy show but
you know he's he's just a terrible
terrible
terrible way to hit on women and so this
is a terrible time for his book to come
out
governor cuomo's big book of pick-up
lines
we have a copy right here would you like
to hear some of the oh it's
it's terrible it's terrible for example
do you like pizza because i'd like a
pizza that ass this is
he's he's just the worst he's terrible
at this
uh do you come here often or do i have
to move your desk closer
that's not
sex with me is like manhattan
construction it goes all night long
no
[Applause]
you make my heart race like covet
through a new york state nursing home
terrible pickup line uh
did you know long island was named after
my penis was
my brother knows don lemon
[Applause]
i admit i know gavin newsom do you
really want to date a governor who's
prettier than you
you